حصلت للتو على مقطع فيديو جديد لمعركة
ضواحي كييف ، وهو جزء مما
يبدو الآن أنه هجوم مضاد أوكراني أوسع
، ما أنت على وشك
رؤيته هو معركة بالأسلحة النارية على طول خط سكة حديد يقع على
بعد 18 ميلاً شمال شرق المدينة
التي ستذهب إليها  لسماع أحد الجنود
الذين تمكنوا من النزول من ثلاث جولات آر بي جي
في تتابع سريع ، يصرخ الله أكبر
، يقول السياسي الأوكراني الذي نشر
مقطع الفيديو هذا إنه وآخرون
هم في الواقع مقاتلون شيشانيون مهاجرون
حملوا السلاح ضد روسيا.
يجب أن نشير إلى ذلك مع وضع ذلك في الاعتبار
، ها هو مقطع الفيديو
[موسيقى]
أوه
نجاح باهر
[موسيقى]
مرحبًا
هذه المقبرة العسكرية تعيد إلى الوطن
الواقع الصارخ الذي تعيشه أوكرانيا
منذ سنوات مع
كل هذه الصلبان التي تمثل
قبور الأوكرانية  الجنود الذين
لقوا حتفهم وهم يقاتلون ضد الانفصاليين المدعومين
من روسيا في منطقة دونباس منذ عام 2014
وفي هذا الجانب لدينا
قبور
جديدة وهم
مكرسون للضحايا
من روسيا في  vasion of Ukraine الذي
تم إطلاقه في 24 فبراير من هذا
العام ،
أحد القتلى هو ميخائيل زاديراكا
المولود في عام 1997 وكان
عمره 25 عامًا فقط
، وإذا أتيت إلى هنا ،
فسترى شيئًا آخر
وهو تذكير بمدى كآبة هذا الصراع الذي توصلت
إليه السلطات  عشرات
القبور الإضافية التي
تتوقع احتمال وقوع المزيد من
الضحايا
في هذا الصراع الرهيب ،
تمثل شاحنة التبريد هذه
جانبًا آخر من هذه الحرب ، حيث كانت متوقفة
خارج
مشرحة المدينة ويقول مسؤولو المدينة
إنها مليئة جزئيًا
بجثث حوالي 350 جنديًا روسيًا ، وهناك
ثلاجة أخرى  يقولون إن الشاحنة
متوقفة في جزء آخر من المدينة
مع حوالي 400 جثة روسية
وعندما تأتي إلى هذا الجانب
يمكنك شم رائحة الجثث النتنة
يقول المسؤولون الأوكرانيون إنهم
يجرون اختبارات الحمض النووي
للموتى الروس وأنهم كذلك  ثم يذهبون لإرسال
هذه الجثث إلى العاصمة الأوكرانية لإعادتها
في نهاية المطاف
إلى روسيا
وإلى العائلات
بشكل مناسب  دفن
ايفان واتسون سي ان ان نيبال اوكرانيا